écoutez la situation est très tendue à
rerson la ville est bombardée tous les
jours par les rues on a passé la journée
là-bas et on a entendu en effet tout au
long de la journée des explosions
puisque les combats se ont lieu juste à
quelques kilomètres du centre-ville de
rerson au niveau de la ligne de fond
cette liste de front qui se trouve le
long du Nièvre alors leur des
bombardements russes il y a des
immeubles de civils et des maisons qui
sont bombardées nous avons rencontrés
par exemple une femme dans la rue qui
était assez affolée elle nous a expliqué
qu'elle cherchait de l'aide puisque ça
maison avait été bombardée dans la nuit
les Russes bombardent également les
infrastructures énergétiques et vous le
savez ce depuis début octobre leur but
est évidemment de mettre à mal
l'électricité ici en Ukraine pour que
les Ukrainiens se retrouvent sans
chauffage et sans électricité alors
mercredi 50% de la ville de rerson avait
encore de l'électricité mais à cause des
bombardements qui ont eu lieu cette nuit
et bien personne s'est retrouvé
totalement sans électricité ce matin
à peu à peu été rétabli mais le problème
est bien c'est qu'à chaque fois les
autorités réparent ce qui a été
endommagé les Russes frappent à nouveau
les lignes sont à nouveau endommagées
ils font donc tout recommencer c'est un
cercle vicieux qui n'en finit pas pour
le moment alors pour aider les
Ukrainiens les aider un petit peu pour
affronter le froid différents centres
d'invincibilité ont été aménagés dans
toute l'Ukraine il y en a plusieurs
milliers notamment à airsson nous y
avons été tout à l'heure ici les
Ukrainiens peuvent trouver du chauffage
de l'électricité de quoi recharger leur
portable internet aussi une boisson
chaude ça leur permet et bien d'avoir un
petit moment on va dire un petit moment
de convivialité de pouvoir retrouver
quelques personnes de pouvoir discuter
une vieille dame nous a expliqué bien
qu'elle venait ici notamment chercher un
peu de réconfort